la vraie bataille du concorde de la
bataille commerciale tous azimuts et
maintenant commencé la bataille de la
rentabilité si vous préférez concorde
jusqu'à aujourd'hui et est l'emblème du
génie français pardon du du génie
franco-britannique qui se battait contre
les méchants américains jaloux d'avoir
trouvé plus fort que lui
plus fort que pardon au moins dans ce
domaine là c'est vrai aussi dans
quelques autres domaines d'ailleurs mais
à partir d'aujourd'hui fini les emblèmes
fini les cocoricos les compagnies qui
exploitent concorde vont enfin pouvoir
montrer ce qu'elles peuvent
eq ce qu'elles savent faire c'était en
effet aujourd'hui la première liaison
commerciale
après d'innombrables vol de prestige et
d'essai entre paris et new york au
confort et également entre londres et
new york
les deux appareils d'air france et de
british airways s'opposer à deux minutes
d'intervalle sur l'aéroport kennedy le
concorde français s'envoler à 11h ouvre
de roissy charles de gaulle 3 heures 38
minutes plus tard il se poser à new york
mais j'en ai peut être trop dit
retrouvons jean pierre qui tarde
maintenant à bord du concorde
paris new york en trois heures et demie
et bien c'est chose faite depuis
aujourd'hui après 22 mois d'attentes 21
mois et 18 joueurs fassent exactement
désormais tous les jours à 15 mille cinq
cents mètres d'altitude et à 2200 km
heure concorde reliera paris à new york
en deux fois moins de temps que le plus
rapide des boys ce qui permettra ainsi
de faire l'aller-retour en une journée
prenez dans ces conditions que beaucoup
de gens aient voulu suivre et voulu voir
et voulu assister à ce premier vol
inaugural
parmi eux j'ai remarqué de personnes
assiste presque côte à côte
andré turcat le pilote d'essais de
concorde et maurice pellon celui qui il
ya 47 ans a fait le premier prix new
york avec dieudonné costes
écoutez bien en 37 ce 22 novembre 1977
15 ans presque jour pour jour après la
signature du programme concorde mart
dont une étape importante pour le
supersonique une étape vers la
rentabilité
c'est à dire vers les 2750 heures de vol
par an et par appareil
puisqu'avec un vol quotidien vers les
reports de kennedy la moyenne passe en
1/16 sans heurts et avec deux vols
quotidiens vers new york ce qui se
passera vraisemblablement dès cet été
nous serons à 2200 heures par an et par
appareil
doué vous le comprenez l'importance
attachée depuis toujours à new york et
qui pourrait peut-être donner puisque la
ligne maintenant ouverte qui pourrait
donner donc lui à une coopération
franco-américaine un peu à l'image de ce
qui va se passer le 9 décembre prochain
entre british airways et singapore
airlines sur la ligne
londres/singapour encore là donc gagné
la bataille de new york
la bataille du bruit et cela grâce aux
efforts et aux procédures très
particulière mais en place par les
équipages comme celui qui a travaillé
aujourd'hui tout au long de ce vol
inaugural équipage conduit par le
commandant pierre dudin un peu avant 14h
le premier contact est établi avec la
tour de kennedy la descente commence ay
n'avions alès posait ce premier vol
faisait déjà partie de la routine comme
par enchantement le new york qui
accueille aujourd'hui concorde se trouve
être bien différent de celui qui lui
refuser le droit d'atterrir des trois
chaînes de télévision américaines qui
ont retransmis en direct l'atterrissage
ont très bien peu d'écho aux dernières
protestations des riverains et les hôtes
d'air france et le british airways
seront reçus à déjeuner par de multiples
associations commerciales et
industrielles de new york tout comme si
la ville voulait se faire pardonner
d'avoir fait attendre si longtemps
concorde tf1 new york